in a number of spots in this legal  filing Trump's lawyers put quotes around  the word classified when talking about  classified documents and they decry in  the filing that the government has  unilaterally determined that these are  so-called classified documents  think about that  think about the level of desperation  that you have reached when you're legal  filing  attacks the fact that the government and  the government alone has determined  documents are classified and you call  that classification into question with  quotation marks who else determines the  classification of documents who else  gets to decide